A RULES COMMITTEE MEETING FOR
MONDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH. OTHER
RULES CRAZE CALLED ORDER. PLEASE
SHE ADVICE AND AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
BEING MADE AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. AUTOMATIC SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY.
HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE ALLEN BRO
HIP.
CARILLO HERE TORONTO SHARE
FRIEDMAN GRAYSON HERE. HAS AREA
SOLACE
DOESN'T WALDRON. OR HAVE A FORM.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVE OVER SOUTH SECOND EVELYN MR
BRELO. OF ANSWERED CRITICS CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY.
BY COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE ALLEN BROUGH
BONTA BROUGH AYE CORREO AYE
CARILLO EYES TO RUN TESTS AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON.
AYE GRAYSON AYE NAZARIAN SOLACE.
SALAS AYE WALDRON ON WALDRON
EYES MUCH.
OF THE MOTION TESTS AND THE
RULES FOR THESE INSURANCE